they're also quiet
what are you expecting but it's a great
pleasure to be here thank you very much
to the city of Copenhagen for inviting
us my name is Paul hole engraver and the
director of public programs of the New
York Public Library where I often say my
goal is to make the lion's roar we have
two lions in front of the library called
patience and fortitude so my goal there
is to make them roar and to make that
heavy institution levitate it would seem
that Denmark is very much on my mind for
the moment it's nearly become a second
homeland
I just was at the UN opening the
trusteeship council chamber as you may
know Casper Zelda and Thomas SIG's guard
redid chairs for the chamber and was
complicated because they used to be 92
members and now there are hundred and
ninety-three members and the shapes of
people have changed but they had to do
it in the style of he knew so I know how
to say phone'll now I would like to
thank Lisa Bach Hansen very very much
for inviting us here today and for
taking this risk this risk of speaking
about Kierkegaard I'm trying to
pronounce him correctly too and it's a
great pleasure to have Pascal open air
here me too
we've we've known each other for many
many years and I'm looking forward to
talking to you about your rediscovery of
Kierkegaard but in order to do this I
think it's appropriate for me to begin
with a quotation from Kierkegaard from
his journals listen carefully it will
give you a sense also of the style of
Kierkegaard and then I'll have Pascal
react to it maybe I'll read it from the
anthology here
from his journals it's called a sad
reflection in one of the forms it is
said of the rich man that he heaps up
treasures with great toil and knowest
not who shall inherit them so I shall
leave behind me intellectually speaking
a capital by no means insignificant and
alas I know full well who will be my
heir
whenever eta it is that figure so
exceedingly distasteful to me that till
now has inherited all the best and will
continue to do so the docent the
professor yet this also is a necessary
part of my suffering to know this and
then go calm Leon with my endeavor which
brings me toriel and trouble and the
profit of which in one sense the
professor will inherit in one sense for
in another sense I take it with me and
then cuckoo God puts his note and even
if the professor should chance to read
this it will not give him pause and will
not cause his conscience to smite him No
this too will be the subject of a
lecture and again this observation if
the professor should chance to read it
do you understand me this will not give
him pause
no this too will become the subject of a
lecture for longer even than the
tapeworm which recently was extracted
from a woman even longer is a professor
and the man in whom the professor is
lodged cannot be rid by this by any
power only God can do it
if the man himself is willing so in some
sense Kierkegaard will always be the
inspiration against his better judgment
for professors yes so we'll try not to
act as professors tonight yes exactly
and to to act as an ordinary readers and
through the quotation you just made
we understand that Kierkegaard is quite
difficult to understand it seems at
first and it was an easy quotation yeah
I know I know you could have mean I I
chose something really easy to write now
I know even me I could understand so but
yes that's a first-look kickabout seems
a very simple philosophers nothing to do
with the german idealists and when you
go deeper into his work then it becomes
darker and darker and the more you read
and the less you understand and in this
quotation there is many aspects of
course his hatred of university as you
know Kierkegaard was never a professor
Norman husband nor a preacher nor
irreverent so he spends he was mainly
not yes yes yes he didn't want to become
anything like this that there is a last
touch of pride when he says that only
God could understand him and it reminds
me a sentence which is attributed to
Hegel
he says and when Hagar died at the end
of his life on his deathbed he said
nobody has read me and those who read me
did not understand me which is a maybe
true but in fact in this sentence you
quoted the Kierkegaard is closer to
haters and so she wouldn't have liked
them I would not write it but he's not
here anymore so he cannot contradict us
yes yes but but give God your
relationship to him I'm curious about
this because you said he is so difficult
to
read and you for the last in preparation
of this afternoon you have been I have
subjected you to an intense reading yet
of kiss yes no no I had and so tell me
how you feel well I feel well now being
here with you in Copenhagen as a city
which I like very much but in in my use
for the people of my generation
Kierkegaard was used as a tool against
the dominance of Marxism and so you know
in in the 60s and 70s it was not Hegel
who was a dominant philosopher it was
Marx and the existence at least current
use Kierkegaard to contradict these
power of Marxism which was saying nearly
the same thing as Hegel we are all parts
of a history that passes us and our
personal destiny do not have any
importance so we don't have to consider
the individual we have to consider the
movement which leads that's what the
people saw that this time invariably
from capitalism to communism and if
people like yes first another and sad
elected Kierkegaard as a founding father
of existence arisen and in fact it's a
retrospect election because the word
existence charism appears for the first
time in a letter which Jasper's wrote to
an event in 1937 and so it's a kind of
consecration but was Mortimer so cuckoo
God didn't know he was an existential no
I didn't know that no no he thought it
was just a suffering danish christian
struggling against the official church
so when south merleau-ponty and many
others elected Kierkegaard to a club
that they belonged to yes as a master as
a precursor is they try to revive the
importance of the individual
against systems that wasn't crying to
globalize them and exactly as
Kierkegaard didn't want to be disabled
by the Hager system we didn't want to be
counted for nothing
into the communist intelligentsia so he
was Rick as a quotation I mentioned at
the beginning Kierkegaard is always
recuperated yes always that's his
destiny and it's the best thing you can
imagine for a philosopher and for a
writer so until the sixty kirkegaard was
just the object of prophecies
unfortunately it was worshipped by
scholars and university and then his
works have been published in France in
Pocket Books how'd you say live with the
posh nobody pocketbooks is right yes
thank you and you you actually you
actually do a pocket yes
thank you for translating English and
and then it became accessible to every
kind of reader and you know the the
strength of this philosophy which is in
fact an anti philosophy the strength is
that it applies to every death subject
Diary of a seducer the concept of
anguish treaty of despair that was
something which was speaking to us
immediately we didn't have to do to deal
with heavy German idealism which is of
course also magnificent but so
magnificent that when disappear as a
reader into the pages keeper God was
like a grand browser speaking to each of
us you have problem with with seduction
you have problem with your anxiety you
have problems with your freedom you
sometimes tempted by despair read my
book and I will give you not an answer
but at least I will give you a good
question yeah good question and and a
guide to to move into into your life and
that explains its immense success during
those years and it explains also why I
hope we are going to read him again
today's that we celebrate his
Bicentennial but to go back a tiny
little bit to the period in which you
read him intensely you you were brought
up as it were I mean in the world that
that mattered to you was precisely that
world of existentialism and you were
saying you know that he didn't know and
I'm reminded when you say this of the
fantastic line by Boris who says that
every writer creates his own precursors
and in some way Kierkegaard created his
whole destiny as it were destiny of
future readers and in Gabrielle Marcel
in Jasper's in Hanna and
insult he found his best ears or did he
not yes yes absolutely
hairs and Twitter's also traitors yes
Richard years because there's not
treasured great treasures Twitter's
Creighton yeah people were betrayed him
but you know I think this is also the
destiny of a writer if we betrayed when
you are being read by people after you
but you know I wonder when you say
traitor I also wonder about translation
because you know the famous traductor it
reddit or a traitor translator and I
wonder you know I wonder what it is like
I know the city hosts read reads Kagame
yes and I just wonder how much we gain
or lose in translation because I must
say rereading Kierkegaard for me in
small in small dosage not big I do not
suggest reading him for 10 consecutive
days as I've done it's really not very
good for you
but if you read if you read him for a
while he is really pleasurable he writes
so beautifully oh yes yes I mean it's a
great style yes that's why also why the
French love him it's because he's a
literary man he he's been brilliant in
treaties in poetry in novels in
philosophy and doesn't have these heavy
writing of
German philosophy Kant Hegel Schrager
Schilling and all also Heidegger of
course which is the most difficult to
understand even in German so I'm quite
happy to read the Kierkegaard in French
because in French is already very
difficult to understand I think in
Danish it would be impossible for me to
get a line and we were lucky yes we were
lucky so I have no way to test the
quality of the translation I don't know
if it's good or bad but I compared a few
translation made by different
translators and it fits yeah it's you
know 20 years after 30 years after it
does fit well he's very mean in that way
by saying it fits it also means that
he's very urgent
he's very modern in some way yes his
Virgin especially in small aphorism
which he uses and we remember a kick a
guard not through his system because in
fact doesn't have a system or it changed
systems during his life but he made many
beautiful lines which we love to
remember what line do you love to
remember all for instance he said
somewhere he said I want give me some
possible or as suffocate it's not I'm
not giving the exact quotation but will
have will soon be speaking about one
line that will project that you've
probably seen without the infinite
possibility why does that line touch you
oh it touches me because when you're a
teenager when you're 16 or 17 and you
are yourself suffocating adores the yoke
of a family of familiar of religion did
you suffocate from religion oh yes
definitely I was brought up in the
Catholic religion which was at this time
not anymore because now Christianity is
disappearing from France but of course
you know in I was living in the French
province in Lyon in the 60s and life was
not exactly as brilliant as it is today
so kicker God was for me one of the door
which open on the outside word and for
what did he show you what did he when
you look through that window but he said
he said something very simple but which
which still remains essential he said
that and then all the existence at least
philosophy reprised it he said that
freedom and he's always related to
anguish they cannot be freedom without
anguish and they cannot be anguish
without freedom and it's so interesting
to think of the word anguish itself
which literally means to have one throat
be tight
yes exactly your leg your throat is
being tired but your your your chest is
breathing again so you know it was one
of those leaders which took me out with
many others out of operation out of
mediocrity out of everyday life which is
exactly what you require from a writer
when you're a young man even when you
are an older man older man I like I'd
like to remember this sentence that that
a writer and in this particular case
let's consider keyguard first and
foremost perhaps a great writer takes
you out of mediocrity yes yes I mean
very few things do that now very putting
a lot of hope in the power of words and
literature to believe they can do that
yes if people ever read again which is
the most important issue nowadays you
know less and less people are reading
books at least in France but I I guess
it's the same in all over Europe but if
you have the chance to read him
if you risk read if your risk reading if
you do the effort to open a book and not
only play on your screen you might have
you might be able to play on the screen
and reserve to God and yes you might
have a happy surprise to be taken away
from your own personal life which is
always in a way of jail and your we are
enjoying ourselves so Kierkegaard opens
a window and and for this reason I'm I'm
very grateful to him
what what do you think he would make of
this meeting I think it would be at the
same time extremely flattered and
extremely disappointed he would hate us
all and that's I mean that's the
specials the particularity of
Kierkegaard so whenever he has a stand
he immediately jumps to the opposite
side you know you can never catch him
and says that's his philosophy no
because he's already somewhere else he's
always running from one point to the
other so he's kind of taking us by
surprise from behind yet from behind
from from every time every side but that
maybe that's why he makes an ology of
possibility because he never wants to be
caught into a system he always evades
any kind of definition but I think he
would be pleased somewhat that non
professors are speaking about him at
least we are speaking about him in a non
professorial way and then we'll have
Rene Redzepi come here and talk to us in
a yet another way about him so in some
way the urgency that he was hoping for
and the posthumous fame I mean he was
interested in people reading him later
so at least we've given him that you
have said in an essay on on Kierkegaard
that he renounced life and that it is in
some way a core of his philosophy and
you also say that in the title of the
essay you say that he is a Christ who is
a dandy I'd love which I find
fabulous I was trying to understand what
both both of these terms might mean and
what it means for him to have renounced
life and I might quickly add because all
of this could fit
comfortably in an in a good answer of
yours that you you create kind of a
lineage for kierkegaard ancestors and
followers the followers the more most
recent followers we've spoken about him
there some that are even reading
Kierkegaard in France and elsewhere
today but you create a Mel who wrote a
journal of about 10,000 pages Goncharov
who wrote one very important book
Oblomov with a character that's strictly
speaking nothing and kept guard himself
in that as an heir to to those two and
then Melville and particularly in
Melville my single favorite short story
of his which his Bartleby where he
famously says I would prefer not to well
that's a huge question okay I will I
will I will give you a large amount of
time yes go
so Kierkegaard said one time to his
secretary divine he told him how lucky
you are to be Jewish because he was if I
were not born in Christianity I would
probably have lived the lives and so we
have to remember that the fate of
Kierkegaard is a closely related to
sacrifice as a reason anecdote which
every key card reader knows and which is
good to remember when his father was a
young shepherd in jute and a very poor
area of Denmark at this time it was
twelve and one day he addressed he spoke
to God and say why did you choose for me
such a miserable fate it was like a
curse and so he shows is he showed his
anger against God and a few years after
it was sermon in Copenhagen by one of
his uncles and he made a fortune in
selling capsizing caps and buttons that
closes and if so is fortune not as a
sign of a blessing but as a sign of
which is of course very interesting
because most most of the rich people's
things have been elected by God and not
cursed by God but this this feeling of
course he has been transmitted to his
own children and Kierkegaard always sold
servant care guard always so that he
would die before 33 because I think he
lost five or six of his brothers and
sisters he lost his mother and so he
always thought that he was predestined
to an early death and that's why I think
you said it new presentations that's why
I was more related to his father than to
his mother and so he decided very early
birth really absurd yes this was totally
absent so that's why he sort of himself
at the very beginning of his life that
he was to be sacrificing himself to the
sin of his own father and that's why I
decided and the journal shows it
extremely precisely that he was the man
to whom nothing ever would happened and
what does that mean that means that he
failed in every domain if you speak
about the vitality of failure yeah
exactly this variety is a pleasure of of
failing and that we fail to become a
professor he failed to be a lover to
course in he could never marry regime
original sin' he failed to be a preacher
it felt to be reverent and his only
energy was invested in writing and
that's why it's so interesting when you
read for instance the diary of the
seducer you think it will be like
libertine book in the same style as a
cadet role a clue or Casanova
do you remember the cover in the leave
of the bush was a very intense man
looking at you in the French edition yes
and I remember being 15 or 16 and
getting that book and reading it on the
beach and thinking wow this might help
but yes exactly but and and you know
this is dense man it's funny you said
that in these intense men looks like
those those posters in America Uncle Sam
wants you yeah and these intense meant
was saying you can do it if I can do it
so we open this book with quite
expectation expectation of hybridity and
in fact it has very little to do with
seduction very very little to do with
women it is just a pure mental exercise
and it's interesting to notice that kick
a God in spite of his disgust for
official philosophy especially German
philosophy continues a line which starts
with the God live needs
count and the niche of virginity as if
Philosopher's were forming a long line
of priests dedicated to the deity of
virginity as if a philosopher to exist
had not to commit himself with the
pleasures of the flesh and that's very
interesting because think needs ohms
somewhere says philosopher should a bore
marriage and the only one who with a
beaming hate hate marriage the only
exception to that was Socrates and
that's why he married an ugly wife ugly
and a very angry wife these exceptions
that confirm confirm very promising for
philosophers no but I think I think this
kind of attitude may have changes the
20th century in specially the 21st but
so so what giving giving away the
pleasures of the flesh giving away yes
the only present in which kick a God in
dirt when he was young was the pleasure
of cooking he was going in nice
restaurant he was dressed elegantly
that's why I called him dandy Christ he
didn't have any money problems because
his father left him a huge fortune which
he years of
spend spend west of the way because he
never worked through its up the dandy
part yes that's a dandy part of course
but so Kierkegaard for me is philosopher
of the dodging of life how to avoid any
kind of commitment in everyday life and
that's what that's that what makes him
very interesting and maybe the founding
stone of a new lineage which you
mentioned before like um Yale who was
with him in Berlin in I think 1840 and
for those who don't do not know Emil and
nobody knows even not even in France as
you say he's a writer of a huge diary of
16,000 pages 16 16,000 pages and the
diary so it's five times the length of
La Rochelle yes yes but not with exactly
the same interest and why is it
interesting in spite of this it's
because I'm yell like [ __ ] God and many
others after him discover a new
dimension of reality which appears in
the 19th century which is banality this
kind of new dimensions of the time how
to live when nothing happens to you
when everyday looks like the previous
one and looks like the next one and this
dimension of banality is really relevant
in Amir's diary which is a long notation
about the weather in Geneva is small
pains in his body he's meeting with
people and every day writes it right
it's like keeps a journal of his
temperament yes and it's a huge monument
to nothingness which which I think you
should go out and buy it immediately yes
it's a huge monument to nothingness and
and keep you goddess replace nothingness
by the prolific and wonderful work of
reflection upon every
Specht of life but then in fact you also
quoted the oblem of the hero of
Goncharov and abramoff is this this mad
in GaN sheriff's novel were decided that
his life started with extinction and we
decided when he was very young to remain
in his bed and never to move out of the
sweetness of the blanket I mean it made
me think that another person we could
put in this pantheon you have
constructed is we smalls this is sent in
aqua boo who also spends his life
encased having servants wearing slippers
that make no noise having a turtle in
his home on which he encrusts diamonds
living a totally aesthetical life the
aesthetical life I'm bringing it up in
part because you were saying there was a
repudiation of it in kakugane and yet he
had such a incredible love of opera and
he had an incredible love of Don
Giovanni which you heard as you walked
him I'd like us to look at for a very
brief time the catalogue scene and for
you to comment on that particular moment
in Don Giovanni if we could look at it
well it's a wonderful record but Don G
Don Giovanni didn't write any book about
his own conquest and I think Kierkegaard
is a man who decided to remain backstage
in life he also says that in his journal
he said that the he was always an
observer observing the customs and ways
of being of his contemporaries but not
engaging himself in anything except
writing and except strolling in
Copenhagen he was sitting at cafe and
looking at people and so we never had
not 1003 ladies not even one and that's
extremely interesting as I said before I
decided so to sacrifice his own life to
redeem
scene of his father right and his
redemption is infinite and and
impossible to achieve and impossible to
achieve and we but in these sacrifice
there is huge pride is a huge vanity
also because at the end of his life
vanity
yes kicker got sort of himself as the
witness of God as the Envoy of God as
the poet of God and spokesperson
spokesperson of God and of course this
is a position which is not very easy to
adopt especially when you have an
official Church that's why he spent the
last years of his life attacking the
little in church but which is
interesting in Kierkegaard's faith and
that's why we can read him even we are
not believers yeah I was going to ask
you because here you are in in the past
couple of weeks rereading Kierkegaard
you may have been a choir boy when you
were 13 years old you may have had a
difficult upbringing when you were 16
years old in leo but here you are a few
years later reading Kierkegaard many
ways letter a few yes few years thank
you yeah a few years later reading
Kierkegaard discovering how difficult it
is and discovering maybe that it doesn't
get easier with age and you're reading
him without any crutch or any help from
religion quite on the contrary you're
reading him as someone who if I may be
so bold as to say is a non-believer does
it make sense to read Kierkegaard in
such a secular decontextualized way yes
it makes sense for for two reasons for
two different reasons the first one is
that Kierkegaard uses
figures of a rhetoric figure which is
paradox for instance in is a Treaty of
despair
it says no man and it says there is a
sin not to believe it in sin it's a sin
to to despair about sin but it's also a
sin not to despair about sin and it's a
sin to despair as for the random
redemption of seen so you know with him
you never know where you stand
you think you have understood one
proposition and then he it takes the
different standpoint and that's why
Kierkegaard is giving us as many
arguments in favor of God and as many
arguments against God he says somewhere
I don't even remember where where he
said religion are like travel agent
agencies that promise you a nice trip to
the beyond but nobody ever came back
from the heaven to say it was worth the
trip that's really as a phrase of an at
least so that's the first point my
second point is a fantastic line it's a
fantastic line can you say it again so
he says that religions because I think
it's important I like trade travel
agencies which permits you a safe trip
to the beyond but nobody ever came back
from heaven to tell you it was worth the
trip you understand
I do understand I translated from the
French so no I do understand and I you
know and why is because Kierkegaard has
been a reluctant Christian in in his
first years he finally decided to
embrace theology but had a lot of
difficulties to get this diploma and
this doubt you can feel it all over his
writing until the end and that's what's
making very interesting because as an it
is myself I can read him with a lot of
interest and I think this is a great
difference by the way between
Christianity and another religion like
Islam Christianity always includes at
since santoku snap Pascal a dimension of
doubt about the idea of God Judaism also
God exists but we don't know exactly
under which form and the promises he
makes us to us are not so certain after
all
whereas for the moment Islam is a one
block of faith which nobody can
challenge and these uncertainty in
Christianity you can feel it in a
Kierkegaard speeches and and books
the other reason for which we can read
kick-out nowadays in addict westernized
world
I found it in a communication with
Robert shaft made in 1966 in Paris at
uni school which is a UN cultural cyber
Union it was a big reunion which
gathered famous philosophers about
Casper's Gabrielle Marcel Emmanuel
Levinas
Jean Val and supersoft and thought
speaks about the scene and he said me as
an artist I do not believe in seen in
the original scene and that's so amusing
to read when you you you have read
thoughts books because thought never
cease to inject shame and guilt in his
readers mind never ceases there never
ceases yeah in other words there is
always shame there is always shame there
is a guiltless forever
there is at face a bad face of the
waiter in a cafe is that place to be a
waiter it's a bad face of each office
when we refuse our freedom and try to
refi ourselves and excellently I I in
remembering the scene from let alone a
over gas hob cafe exactly a waiter in
Oh waiter I was thinking that you know
in a way sucker was a really good ear of
Kierkegaard because he really made
philosophy palpable
yes really he made it he made it huh -
he made it like a novel yes exactly like
Kierkegaard said he animates Seattle
plays he maneuvers and you know but--
laughs say some things that civilization
civilization is the abandonment of the
original scene but it's very interesting
to note that we have as Sakura people
reintroduce the original scene in every
field of our lives personal success love
life political life and our appreciation
of the West as a global culture is all
also marked by the original sin of
capitalism colonialism slavery our
treatment of immigration so also we
proclaim not to be Christians anymore so
the original scene which has been so
largely described by Kierkegaard is
still marking us deepening our souls
sadly because we have little time left
and I could continue talking with you at
least for two hours and two hours with
Syria as well as with Bernie and I hope
you can all stay until about 9:30 but
we're Adly I'll have a couple more
questions and then we'll call this our
our first case who guard session you
know it reminded me when he was talking
about Baudelaire that he has this
wonderful line I've always loved he says
that even if God didn't exist it
wouldn't be a good enough reason not to
believe in him yes but in fact this is
very Christian yeah I mean it's the most
brilliant I mean it comes to me as I
look at you yeah thinking this this is
interesting
no no exactly yeah I think the most
brilliant minds of Christianity always
started with a doubt about the existence
of God and what is what is interesting
in a Christianity is that it start with
the death of God it's the only religion
which are skill God of course in order
to have him where resurrect three days
after which is a trick we
don't work but you know when you have
killed your own God your own the object
of worship then you can have a big doubt
about the existence of God and it's the
same thing of course in in Judaism and
maybe this is what makes now there is a
Christianity and liberal Judaism so more
agreeable to live because you know it's
a factor of cohesion of coherence you
know it strikes me Pascal that you you
cannot not I mean I don't think you have
it in you to not be a Paulo masses you
need to be a polemicist the other way I
like it yes because I would have to ask
you because I think in god there's a
posturing The Dandy is a string and I'm
wondering if if precisely you might be
able to articulate why Kierkegaard
matters to you as a polemicist
because you yourself for one yes is a is
a very brilliant poly missus and he
always writes with an enemy behind his
shoulder and I also do you yes yes maybe
two or three because you know they're
still alive do you know the line of
Sartre who said that he brought when he
was asked why he wrote theater he said
Putin elihpa Coulomb is in me to give
the word to my enemy anyway continue
given anyway that's answers which is a
very good attitude because as South said
also you always have to think against
yourself but when you read the
Kierkegaard you know he alludes
constantly of course - hey girl but this
is very well note but also to more
obscure philosophers of reverence of his
time against which he fights and and
then when you have these moments of
Torah mix it awakens you because you
know you you
it's like it's like ass word e-courses
this word sue someone else flesh and you
like him because it makes is writings
very lively it's not an exporter of of
an ideas or of an opinion it's a polemic
and I think philosophy must be created
through polemics two to two more quick
comments one since you grew up as it
were under the guise of existentialism
there's one philosopher not Sakura but
kami who in the myth of Sisyphus has
this to say Kierkegaard may shout in
warning if man had no eternal
consciousness if at the bottom of
everything
there were merely a wild seizing force
producing everything both large and
trifling in the storm of dark passions
if the bottomless void that nothing can
fill and delay all things that what
would life be but despair this cry is
not likely to stop the absurd man
seeking what is true is not seeking what
is desirable if in order to elude the
anxious question what would life be one
must like the donkey feed on the roses
of illusion than the absurd mind rather
than resigning itself to falsehood
prefers to adopt fearlessly
Kierkegaard's reply despair everything
considered a determined soul will always
manage I'm wondering if you feel
sympathetic to this view of kami
well I don't feel auntie partaking at
least but I'm not sure to understand it
exactly but yes you can start your own
life with despair and then
embrace it with passion Kierkegaard says
something in his book the concept of
anguish he said that we fear and we flee
anguish as much as we love it but we can
never love it because we have to flee it
and this is this is exactly I think the
definition of freedom which is a very
tempting movement which at the same time
you're afraid to to commit yourself into
of course Kiko God stayed on the edge he
never went into life you know he adopted
as I said before the situation of the
observer and at inspector to have no
longer yes not only my age non engaged
spectator but at the end of his life he
seems in his journal to regret this
attitude and Tobias found yeah by
standard and obviously friendship love
passion where never is is main pleasures
but we can read kicker God and then
commit ourselves engage ourselves into
ordinary life without losing our souls
with without becoming a double of him
yeah without becoming a double of him
and but we don't do not have we do not
only have fatherly sins to atone for
thankfully in closing I'm going to be
doing a little experiment you mentioned
that Kierkegaard really works well as a
number of quotations as a number of
moments that are important and I suffer
from a terrible disease which all of you
will be privy to to this afternoon which
is I suffer from something called quote
Romania I seem not to be able to stop
quoting it's a disease from which I wish
no cure but I suffer from it quite
deeply and I think we we we try
different quotations to try out
different reactions also from different
people and
see how we feel about that very
quotation and you know when I mentioned
the Camellia didn't have an enormous
amount of resonance but now mentioning
this Kierkegaard you may say oh my
goodness this means something to me that
is very strong to me this is sort of at
the basis nearly in the core of a
certain form of thinking in Kierkegaard
an existentialist form and this is what
he says and we can maybe put on the
stage that the line that you saw as you
came in I will read it slowly so you
have time to see it my soul has lost
possibility it comes from the the
abyssal Mata in either or my soul has
lost possibility were I to wish for
anything I would not wish for wealth and
power but for the passion of the
possible that I which everywhere ever
young ever-burning sees possibility
pleasure disappoints not possibility and
what wine is so sparkling what's so
fragrant so intoxicating yes it's not
bad and you know the quote Romania is
very often if fear to speak in your own
as a first person you know what I have
it too
but you know I'll tell you when you
interview me next you can you can talk
to me about that the exactly right I do
need help now I will help you look for
your you're absolutely right it's it's a
mask no it's not a mask it's a it's a
way to protect one surface I say it's a
mass yes no go ahead take off your mask
and speaking of in your mind what you
say those this quotation is a beautiful
one it reminds me by the way of note by
poss-eye
refer the photographer and it has a
story about the young muscle post when
muscle force was a young man he fell in
love with the son of a magistrate in
Geneva and of course nothing happened it
was a pure possible and the young man
sent a picture of himself to Masson post
and he had written on these at the back
of this picture a poem by Dante Gabriel
Rossetti and it the line was look at my
see look at my face my name is might
have been I'm also called too late no
more
Farwell and it's a it's a beautiful it's
a beautiful quotation and and you know
it by heart and I know it by heart yes I
know it by heart because I repeated it
to myself many times in French and in
English and in different circumstances
in different circumstances yes and I
think this is Kierkegaard's tragedy he
someone was always preferred the
possibility to the reality and so he
never engaged himself in any kind of
concrete road except writing his books
for fear to miss another opportunity and
this explains also the special tonality
of his work but you could comment your
quotation in a different way
we remain alive whatever our ages as
long as we still have different
possibilities around us and life is
finished when the roads are not before
quitting anymore
when there is just one path to the end
and so for me Kierkegaard remains is a
wonderful oxygen which opens many ways
to different kinds of life that's why
remains for me at least a capital
contemporary pascal bruckner thank you
very much
that's super cool okay call me back call
me Bob
you